Good morning, John.
Happy Pizzamas.
I know I’m still on paternity leave, but
I made this video early because I felt really
bad that I wasn’t gonna be able to make
a Pizzamas video.
Right now I’m walking to a place where a
bunch of people who I like make a bunch of
stuff that I like, and I wanted to show it
off.
It’s Pizzamas specific; I don’t know why
I’m trying to be, like, oblique.
You’re gonna find out right now.
This is Zoo City Apparel.
They’ve been printing shirts for us for
almost three years now, and they print pretty
much every shirt that we sell at DFTBA.
I asked them if I could go visit during this
year’s Pizzamas printing, and they graciously
accepted, and even, amazingly, provided me
with pizza.
So let’s meet some of these people.
This is Chris. He owns Zoo City.
Hank: Why did you start a print shop?
Chris: I have no idea.
Hank: How long ago was that now?
Chris: Ten years.
Hank: Oh my God.
This is Lou.
He’s one of the press operators.
Lou: I started in my garage when I was seventeen.
I went to school for graphic design, then
it took twenty years for it to come back around.
I’m gonna go ahead and send it around, just
this shirt
Hank: Yeah.
Lou: And if you want to walk around, it’ll
go through every head, and it’ll print just this shirt.
Hank: Right.
Lou: It’s gonna look completely different
when it comes out the back.
This is Cory.
He’s the ink guy.
Hank: Do you listen to podcasts while you’re
doing this?
Cory: Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
I was actually listening to yours before you
walked in here, so.
Hank: Oh that’s crazy.
Cory: Yeah.
Printing a shirt isn’t like printing from
a printer.
The colors get made.
The inks get mixed by Cory.
Sometimes he has a formula to start with,
but he usually ends up eyeballing it, and
the color ends up looking different on the
shirt than it does in the bucket, so it’s
a skill that can only be developed with time.
We work with Zoo City because they make a
fantastic product.
They care about making our shirts fantastic,
and they know how to get it done.
I love watching them utilize their skills
to do great work, and I’m very glad that
they were okay with me jumping in their space
to appreciate them making our stuff.
I think, for the most part, businesses want
you to imagine that the things that you buy
are made in Star Trek style replicators because
that’s simple and they don’t want to complicate
the transaction.
They want you to think about the thing, not
the people who made it.
Not necessarily because those people aren’t
happy in their jobs, just because it complicates things.
But I think it’s nice, and also maybe important,
to see a bit of the complexity and the hard
work that goes into the things that I buy
and the things that I sell.
It might not be simple, but I think it’s
more rewarding, and it’s definitely more real.
And frankly, it’s too easy to never appreciate
all of the people who work hard making their
lives and everyone else’s lives a little
bit better every day.
John, happy Pizzamas.
I’ll see you tomorrow, and you will see
me when I get back from paternity leave.